okay good evening everybody and welcome
to tonight's planning committee meeting
my name is peter richards and i will be
chairing the meeting tonight some
administration stuff first of all if you
could please turn your phones off um or
the very least is silent i don't mind if
people want to use their phones but
provided it doesn't disturb the flow of
the meeting so um silence is a minimum
but off if you would we're not expecting
a fire alarm so if one does go off
please follow us out to the windmill car
park we'll make sure that everyone's out
safely and then we can we can send you
on your merry way
um the meeting is being recorded and
live broadcast it is a meeting in public
not a public meeting so only those
people will be that have registered
speak will be permitted to do so at the
appropriate time i'll call you forward
to the chair in the middle here um if
you press the button in the middle of
the microphone it will turn red and
you'll be able to speak and be heard
and i'll let you know how much time
you've got we have got hand sanitizer
gel and we've got desk wipes if you want
to use them please do if you don't want
to use them that's also absolutely fine
some intros um so to my far right we
have ann banks our committee services
representative to my immediate right we
have sue mullins our solicitor and our
planners in a particular order are erin
weatherson sarah chadwick we've got
alice cosnet who will be our planning
manager um for the most of the meeting
but is presenting our first and we have
dale barker to my immediate left who is
going to be our planner manager for the
first item dale i believe you'll have a
statement to make i do thank you
i do thank you chair um my role for the
first item is to provide independent
advice to members and to assist members
in their decision-making thank you chair
marvelous thank you very much let's move
into the agenda proper um our apologies
for absence we have an apologies please
um
thank you yes german we have apologies
from councillors adam and kendall
thank you very much um members do we
have any disclosures of interest please
council redden
uh thank you um item number six twenty
two zero zero three six two ful um i
know one of the speakers dominick
skinner is a friend of mine
um i come to this with a completely open
mind though so
okay
no problem thank you very much cancer
crump
thank you mr german uh application 2103
876 fuel uh i'm the ward member and i
will not be taking part in the debate
but i'm registered to speak jolly good
thank you very much anyone else
council curtis
yes i also know dominick skinner as well
but i come to this with an open mind
okay lovely stuff
anyone else before i give mine
no um so item uh number
three application is 2103 502 rem um in
a previous role uh as the infrastructure
report uh housing portfolio holder i was
involved in early discussions about this
site um but again it's moved on
dramatically since then and i'm here
with an open mind so i will remain um
sharing that item
we have no minutes so we will move
straight into that item so um alice
cosnet is our presenting officer alice
over to you
thank you chairman
the application site as identified by
the black dot in the centre of the plan
is located in strapped upon avon's
built-up area boundary the application
site forms part of the wider area of
land allocated for residential and
commercial development under proposal
sua1 of the core strategy and policy
ssb1 of the ndp
hybrid planning permission was granted
in 2021 for both the blue and red areas
outlined on the plan the hybrid
commission granted 56 dwellings in full
in this area here and up to 500
dwellings in outline along with some
commercial floor space and public open
space the application before members
this evening which is denoted by the red
outline on the plan seeks approval for
the reserved matters relating to
appearance landscaping layout and scale
for phase two
so this slide shows the proposed site
layout phase two comprises of 113
dwellings mainly formed of detached
semi-detached and terraced housing an
apartment block contained in 15
apartments is located in the southeast
corner of the site
102 markets and 11 affordable units are
proposed which is consistent with the
section 106 relating to the hybrid
planning permission
no commercial floor space is proposed
under this phase
and the canal side park lines the air of
the site which fronts the canal with a
crescent of three-story town houses here
and the apartment block as referred to a
moment ago here
the next couple of slides provide some
street scene elevations to give members
a feel for the design of the dwellings
proposed so this slide shows dwellings
within the housing quarter which is
towards the western side of phase two
which comprises more traditional units
of red brick and slate roof construction
details such as white lintels seals to
windows bay windows entrance canopies
and decorative brick cordling will
effectively add visual interest
the crescent of three-story townhouses
an apartment building fronting the pos
can be seen in the bottom two street
scene elevations on this slide
white brick and slate roofs are proposed
in this canal side character area which
is towards the western sorry the eastern
side of phase two
this photo is taken from timothy's
bridge road looking towards the phase
two site members familiar with the site
will notice that the larger dcs
warehouse building which formerly
occupied this area here has been
demolished phase one is just out of shot
to the right hand side of the photo
this photo is taken from the canal
towpath with the phase two site to the
right hand side and the canal to the
left-hand side the morgan syndal office
building can be seen in the distance
here that's located just outside the
application side for phase two
as proposed the canal side park and air
of pos would front this boundary with
the canal
existing hedgerows and security fencing
would be cleared and replaced with a
post and rail fence and native hedging
except where the two pedestrian cycle
accesses to the towpath are proposed as
can be seen in the photo the site
currently comprises a flat area of hard
standing where the dcs building was
formally located
chairman the recommendation is to
approve this reserve matters application
following the resolution of the current
issues raised by the lead local flood
authority as detailed in the report
as detailed in the update sheet
additional information has been
submitted in respect of the llfa's
request for more information and this is
currently being considered by the llfa
there are a couple of other updates
provided on the update sheet
the recommendation to approve is subject
to the conditions set out on pages 22
and 23 of your agendas thank you
chairman
all right thank you very much indeed now
we have no speakers registered on this
item so we will go straight to points of
clarification for our officers
councillor dixon first
thank you chairman alice um in your
report you indicate that
you anticipate
that overall it is expected that the
housing numbers and housing mix will be
as agreed in the outline content
is the whole of the site being developed
by the same developer or is there more
than one developer involved
through you chairman so the whole of the
area outlined in blue and red is being
developed by st joseph holmes and
they've confirmed that they'll be
developing future phases
um the wider canal quarter allocation
encompasses some areas down here and the
other side of the railway line um we
don't know who the developers for that
are
what i will say is that the
full application which was granted as
part of the hybrid included 56 units in
this location and they were all one and
two beds so they were very much skewed
towards the smaller units this area of
the site was always expected to be the
larger housing so expected to be
slightly larger in terms of uh bedroom
numbers but um st joseph has committed
to saying that throughout the um
development of the whole site the
housing that should generally accord
with the housing mix as set out in the
core strategy and ndp
generally yeah
okay
okay any other questions council crump
thank you mr chairman uh alice the
uh update sheet the renewable energy
um the applicant has confirmed that
we'll be looking to incorporate ac
source heat pumps i just wonder how firm
that commitment is
and
the second part and that's a definite
incorporation of pv panels onto the
apartment building please
uh yeah i checked this with the
applicant earlier on today just to
confirm um they have confirmed that in
line with building regs they will be
providing air source heat pumps to
houses and pv panels to apartments if
members were minded to approve only on
the basis of conditions to secure those
that's something which they would be
agreeable to and i don't think we would
have any concerns as officers adding so
that could be something if members were
minded to recommend the attachment of
one or two conditions to secure those
those renewable features
okay any other questions before we move
to the debate
no in that case let's hope not to debate
council jennings
well town council uh have withdrawn
their objections
um
i'm looking i've read this and i can't
see any material planning matters that
would make me go against officer
recommendations
so i'm happy to propose that we
go with the officer recommendations and
approve this subject to the
llfa concerns being resolved and a
condition of renewable
features
okay thank you very much anyone else
council curtis
um
i'm not too happy with the statement
from the developers that should
generally
meet the housing mix
i think
i i just feel that leaves it wide open
for interpretation
i'm not happy with that as it stands at
the moment
okay anyone else would like to
contribute to the debate
council crumb well i'm happy to uh
second counselor journalist proposal no
he's
agreed to the condition about renewable
energy thank you
lovely okay
unless anyone has anything to say we
will move to a vote
no one got anything to say let's move to
a vote so the proposal um that has been
seconded is to approve subject to the
llfa concerns being resolved and with an
additional condition for the renewable
energy could i have a show of hands
please for those in favor
one two three four five six nine two and
those against
one and no abstentions so the uh
committee therefore resolves to grant uh
sorry to approve applications subject to
lfa concerns being resolved uh
application twenty one zero three five
zero two rem
now we must say goodbye to mr barker
thank you very much mr parker for your
time and contribution it's really
invaluable as always
um
and alice will now take the role um as
planning manager alex i'm going to
assume that the statement made by mr
barker earlier on still applies to
yourself that's correct thank you
chairman marvellous okay let's move to
our second item of the evening then uh
which is application
210-3876 ful tourist hotel in southam
our presenting officer is erin welleston
aaron over to you
thank you chairman
the application site lie to the east of
southam as identified by the black dot
on this plan
just here
southam is identified as a main rural
centre within the council's adopted core
strategy the site falls outside of the
build-a-period boundary for the
settlement as identified by the
council's core strategy but within the
draft bill to peria boundary as
identified by the council's emerging
site allocations plan
this slide shows the application site
outlined in red including the associated
visibility displays which go along the
road you can see here and here
the application site comprises a parcel
of brownfield land which formerly
contained a hotel and restaurant and
associates parking to the front and
access
planning permission is sought for the
demolition of the building and the
erection of fort attached dwellings with
two garages and associated works the
building on the site has been demolished
as works have understood to be carried
out in accordance with planning
permission
1900 450 ful which granted planning
permission for the demolition of the
building and the erection of three
dwellings
this slide shows an aerial image of the
site with the approximate location of
the site outlined by the red circle just
here the site lies on the approach to
the settlement and is highly visible
from the daventry road due to the
sloping lands located to the east just
here
and the viewpoints from the road as
you're approaching the site the site
lies approximately 35 metres from the
river stove which is located just here
to the east of the site
to the west to the north of the
application site like dwellings which
fall within calcutta meadows you can see
just here
and to the south of the development lies
residential dwellings across the road
including flying field which is located
just here which is a new development
that's being built out
there have been a number of applications
on this parcel of land
this slide shows the site plans for most
recent applications including the 2019
planning permission i mentioned just
before for the three dwellings on the
site you can see one two three within
the application site the 2020
application which was about eight units
on the site which was refused the 2021
application which is this site plan here
for five dwellings on the site and
associated outbuildings this application
was refused and recently dismissed to
appeal and the final
site plan on this slide is for the
current application we're considering
this evening so for four dwellings and
two out buildings you can see here and
here
this slide shows proposed site layout
compared to the 2019 earlier permission
you can see just here
plot one of the proposed development
will be set approximately one meter
closer to the road
and have a similar height to the extant
permission the development will follow a
similar arrangement arranged around an
access road with a dwelling facing south
onto the daventry road
the development will be for four
dwellings at space across the
application site and the dwellings will
have garages set closer to the boundary
just here
this slide has proposed elevations for
plots one and two and the proposed
garage design the dwarves will be two
story in height with ridge heights
varying approximately between seven
point eight and eight point seven meters
dwellings will be finished in brick and
retal roof with design features
including chimneys pitch roof door
windows and gable
features this slide shows proposed
elevations for plots three and four plot
four is the largest dwelling with five
bedrooms the remainder will have three
bedrooms so plot four just along the
bottom of this slide here
this slide shows the front elevation
plan for plots one to four along the top
of the slide as part of the proposal for
this evening and the house type for the
2019 permission below
this slide shows a number of photographs
taken prior to the demolition of the
building on the site in 2021 the top
left image is looking along the davinci
road and the application site edge is
just here to the right of the image the
next photograph was taken panning around
looking towards the application site and
you can see the building just here and
the vegetation behind
bottom left is just panning across from
across the road you can see the
application building here the access and
the parking and the final photograph on
this slide shows the access to the
application site the access road
adjacent to the application site and the
building and the car park
this slide shows a number of photographs
taken after the demolition of the
building the top
left image was taken looking away from
salvo into the countryside you can see
the open land
just here and the development just to
the south of the daventry road here
the top right image we're taking looking
back towards the application site you
can see enclosed here by the fencing
with the trees beyond and the open land
just here
the bottom left image was taken looking
from the road you can see the access to
the application site and the access road
next to it and the vegetation around the
site and the final image on this slide
was taken looking towards the
application site from the road again the
access is visible and the front of the
site is just here
this slide shows a number of photographs
taken from the wider area the top left
was taken from the development across
the road looking back towards the
application site which is shown by the
approximate location of the arrow just
here the top right was taken from the
access to flying fields to the southern
part of the daventry road looking back
towards the application site which is
just here
the bottom left photograph is taken
looking out towards the countryside with
the application site to the left hand
side of this image
and the final photograph on this slide
was taking a flying field from the
pedestrian access across the road from
the application site
this final slide shows a number of
photographs taken looking within the
application site planning from the
western boundaries around you can see
just here
to the eastern boundary
there are a couple of updates for this
application which have been circulated
on the update sheet it's recommended
that planning permission be granted
subject to conditions and notes set out
within the officer report thank you
all right thank you very much indeed we
will call our first speaker evening who
is councillor andrew walster of southern
town council good evening council and
thank you for your patience
well when you're comfortable and settled
you'll have three minutes and we'll give
you a 30 second warning before your time
is up um otherwise whenever you're ready
it's over to you
thank you very much hopefully i won't
take three minutes of the committee's
time so
good evening everybody thank you for
your time to consider the town council's
objection this evening as detailed by
your officer and in her report the site
has a
long planning history um although being
over a number of years a couple of last
couple of years from eight houses down
to three
the town council is supportive in
principle of development at this site
even though it is outside the
development boundary of the town
because it is currently and has been for
a number of years quite an eyesore to
the entrance to our town to quote a
number of constituents something has got
to be done with the site
the town council supports the existing
2019 application for three houses that
has been approved we know that the
committee and the playing inspector have
turned down the application for five
houses which you've also seen on the
officers report this evening on grounds
of it being over development
we know that all of the public
representations made on the site are
objections on grounds of over
development and that the read and a
number of these objectives have also
said that they support the existing
approved application for three houses
the question that being asked by
residents and by the town council is
there why why therefore your four houses
acceptable
no viability argument has been made by
the applicant to suggest that the site
is not viable with three houses and nor
is one considered by your officer
therefore the only conclusion the town
council and residents can draw is that
this is an increase in houses to
increase the profit level for the
developer whilst in one respect that is
laudable that somebody wants to increase
their profit level for the residents and
the town council that isn't acceptable
on this site
this is therefore pure over development
for profit
there are a number of other points i'd
just like to raise on the
report that's been fought before you
this evening the report considers that
there is a lit footpath from the site
down to the main centre of southam
whilst in practice there is a lit
footpath any pedestrian would need to
cross a four-lane bypass to get to the
southern town centre therefore as with
flying fields it's exactly it's
extremely likely that any future
residents will drive and sell them i
therefore and the town council therefore
do not see how the developer can
discharge the condition to complete the
client in point one of the climate
change checklist which is conditioned as
part of this
application
the south is also bounded to the
northeast by a
working farm and light industrial units
whilst there is some distance no
consideration has been given to noise or
odour complaints that may arise in the
future from this farm to the development
this is something that we should be we
think should be considered
the town council there for us that the
committee respectfully uh refused this
application on grounds of
overdevelopment
marvelous councillor thank you very much
indeed you could marine seated just for
a moment we'll see if you have any
questions for you remember we got any
questions for our counselor
no
okay in that case council thank you very
much for your time and patience this
evening
right we'll move to our next speaker um
who is charlotte l hakeem
good evening and welcome
so similar drill you'll have three
minutes i'll give you a 30 second
warning whenever you're comfortable if
you press the button in the middle it'll
turn red and it is over to you
good evening members and thank you chair
this planning application seeks planning
permission for a direction of four
detached dwellings and garaging this
application follows an earlier and
extant grant of planning permission on
the site with three dwellings
members will note a recent dismissed
appeal for five dwellings the scheme
before members today is significantly
different than what the inspector
reviewed this is clearly set out in your
report but quickly summarizes fewer
properties lower in height with garages
that have been significantly reduced in
height and bulk it is clear the proposed
development meets the criteria of
national policy and it is worthy of note
that inspecting the recent associated
appeal did not have any concerns with
the principle of development
the planning officer in her committee
report recognises that the development
is considered to have been demonstrated
the site is no longer viable or
appropriate for business use
members must tonight consider that there
is an extent planning permission on the
land for the three dwellings which was
weigh heavily in the planning balance
and decision-making process works have
lawfully commenced on site to implement
this scheme and therefore
this prospect exists as a realistic
fallback with the principle of
development established the
consideration therefore for members is
the visual impact of the proposal of one
additional dwelling
in the office's assessment of the scheme
it is clear that the officers not only
compared the scheme against the extent
permission but also the refuse scheme
for five dwellings and subsequent
inspectors decision the officer
concludes the following points in
relation to impact the dwelling includes
design features which i consider
sympathetic to the character of the area
plot one will be cited in a similar
location to the appeal development but
will have a reduced mid chart concluding
that it would be less prominent and
harmful within the street scene she also
cites the proposed development due to
the reduction in heights and buildings
will reduce the perceived mass of the
development compared to the extent
planning permission when viewed on the
approach approach to the settlement
the visual break between the side
elevations of the dwelling will also be
increased above and beyond the extinct
permission
the officer concludes again that she
considers that it would result in a less
mass and more spacious development which
would be more in keeping with the
character of the area overall the
officer states within her report she's
satisfied that the development in its
current form will not result in the harm
of the character of the area and will be
sympathetic to the existing built form
in the line with the council's policies
and the council's spds there are no
technical objections relating to ecology
trees drainage or highway safety
therefore i'd ask members to consider
the revised scheme in front of them
tonight which their officer recommends
for approval the officer is actively
engaged throughout the process and her
judgment has considered the planning
history of the site the office
acknowledges that the proposed scheme
before you this evening is an
improvement in visual impact terms to
the extent permission
exists as a realistic fallback my client
purchased a site with a permission for
three dwellings and has tried to make
more efficient use of the land improve
the design and layer he's committed to
delivering a high quality bespoke and
well proportioned development the layer
has been amended to reduce the number of
buildings including garages this now
creates more spacious layout which would
most closely reflect the extent
permission and achieve the loosening
development the lpa's seeking the
development would reflect the character
and distinctiveness of the locality as
required by core strategy policy as10
thank you for your time
perfect thank you very much indeed
members do we have any questions
you need a couple of minutes to digest
that
if there are no questions we'll move on
no
okay mr kim thank you very much your
time contribution this evening
right we'll move to our final speaker on
this item who is councillor crump
council crump do you come forward
you definitely know the drill five
minutes you'll get a 30 second warning
whenever you're ready the floor is yours
thank you mr chairman uh just
i think what we're missing here at
moment is is the developers saying it's
better than the refused
five bedroom uh that went to appeal
but what we're saying is the town
council and award members it's worse
than an extent three-bedroom so we're
going from three houses to four not from
five down to four so i think that's one
point it's not this i've got no
rejection noise the tank has on the
principle of development on the side and
i think neighbours haven't as well the
ones that have contacted me because i
think the site does need tiding up
but the whole principle of this is we're
going from an exam provision of three
houses to four which is an increase of
33 okay the buildings
it's not necessarily the number of
buildings but the number of houses is
being increased
so that's the that's the principle so i
think we not don't need to be side
shacked on the saying it's better than
the five because the five got refused by
the planning inspector
uh with tank cans and i have a similar
opinion you know basically we think this
is an extra development potentially my
stealth going from eight units to five
to three to four and confusing the
matter and as i already stated that the
town council and i and residents are
reasonably happy with the three houses
on start the extant planning permission
obviously went to uh the planning
inspector the appeal mentioned earlier
was on the 5th of april and this
decision was on the ninth of may
that decision um basically said
uh
it was to do with the size bulk and mass
and concentrating
of the of the site um which made it
really obtrusive
again the proposals density that went to
planning appeal and i think it's in them
to this one was at odds with the
neighbor neighborhood loose knit
development and in fact a marked
contract was the first by used by the
planning inspector and i don't see any
real material change
the combined scale height and
massing of proposed weighings and
associated buildings appear to dominate
and under highly visible to the street
scene and we failed to integrate
successfully with the local contacts and
they again by the time council and the
local residents feel this is still
relevant
like say we are happy to accept three
not four
and with the rich heights um
coming down by half a meter again i
don't think that's significant
uh
again as per the appeal the current
development would not integrate
effectively with the surroundings as
preparer one two four the n double p f
um there is no evidence and again this
has been touched on that the extent
planning permission could not be
implemented or would be unviable
just mention that there is no evidence
that the extent planning permission
could not be implemented or become would
be economically unviable
uh going to the report
yet some of the single story carriages
have been reduced but again i don't
think it's particularly material and i
agree this is where i again disagree
with the officer when she compares the
application with appeal saying that
built form is materially reduced
she should be saying that the built form
is materially increased from the extent
planning permission are you three houses
before
um i don't normally just agree with erin
but in my opinion i think she's got it
wrong here so
apologies there harm erin
um
although the property wouldn't cause
significant highway issues or negative
impact on neighbours living conditions
they they do not outwide the harm caused
to the character and appearance of the
area
it would tidy up a derrick site and i
agree but the benefit of my opinion
would not outweigh the harm
and the
already extent planning commission
targets up the area anyway
as the inspector said although a
brownfield site small benefit would be
insufficient to justify the harm
please refuse this planning application
as an acceptable one currently exists
and neither say them nor the court
strategy is desperate for one more house
in this location thank
you council crump thank you very much
members do we have any questions for
councillor crump please
no in that case council come thank you
very much
right let's move to points clarification
to officers would anyone like to ask our
officers a question council dixon
thank you chairman
erin um can we have a
good analysis of the extent planning
permission in respect of garages and
locations
and a comparison with the application
now are the two
garages being proposed with this
application basically a situation
whereby one garage block is providing a
single garage for each of the properties
etc and will that provide sufficient
parking spaces on that basis on the for
the four
thank you so just to confirm in terms of
what's the extent permission it's this
on the left-hand side of the slide they
all had attached garages with
accommodation above um so in terms of
the garages it was one for each dwelling
and the same design for all the house
types which is just handed so if i just
show you the slides this is a comparison
in terms of the accommodation above the
garages below
in terms of the arrangements we've got a
garage here and a garage here to say
sorry
sorry just over here so we've got one of
the garages here
and a garage here so serving plot one
and plot four
and one of the recommended conditions is
that there is a parking space retained
within the garage for plot four to make
sure sufficient parking for the size of
the house
so one garage for plot one and one
garage for plot four and then we've got
tandem parking for plots two and three
in the middle
if that makes sense so just here and
here
okay any other questions members
council curses
thanks sure um
i don't know i just to
help me out page 31 of the report i'm
just slightly confused on this which i'm
easily confused um
it's talking about the um
sorry where's the previous page uh
demonstrating that the site is no longer
viable or appropriate for business use
because this was something picked up
mentioned by the agent
and the paragraph reads in this case no
supporting information has been
submitted to demonstrate this criteria
has been met
um it's in conflict but then you've gone
to say detailed marketing information
was submitted to support so could you
just give me a bit of clarification on
that paragraph please i apologize for
any confusion in terms of this
application we've not received any
marketing information or any viability
information to say the site's no longer
appropriate or viable for business
purposes which is our policy test by
cs22 however the extent permission on
the site did provide information and we
were satisfied at that time that cs22
have been satisfied in that respect
lovely thank you very much
okay any other questions before we move
to the debate council jennings
on the confirmation of the height of the
new development
it's
compared to the extant permission
what is the difference there
sorry i understand they're similar i'll
just get the ridge heights for you now
if that would help
so for the extent permission looking at
8.9 to the highest part if i just bring
up the plan
and show you on screen
approximately 8.9 to the highest part
on the dwellings with an eaves height of
approximately 4.8 metres on this larger
section and in terms of the heights of
the dwellings that propose as part of
this development it does vary in height
across the site
i think the report sets out the heights
in terms of the approximate heights
which i'll just bring up for you now
believe it's 8.7
um
so in terms of what's proposed the
heights between 7.8 meters and 8.7
meters for the proposed development
okay have you got to follow up the
cancer jennings
no you don't have to
good man
okay unless someone else has any
questions at this point we will move
into the debate
no let's move into the bait then who
would like to kick us off
council dixon
i think what we've got here is a
situation whereby we've got an
application whereby
the four properties being proposed are
smaller than
the three properties which are the
extent permission and it's essentially a
situation whereby to my mind we're only
debating the case of this application
versus the the three extent properties
obviously there is within this report
the possible benefit of removing uh
planning uh
planning permitted development rights
from these plots as opposed to the three
which are currently there but enforcing
that is never the easiest of conditions
as such
can we have the um
shot of the google the air aerial view
please erin which showed the that's the
one can we zoom in at all very very
slightly
i'm sorry i'm not able to zoom in on the
presentation okay um basically my
concern is that the
uh the four are less spacious than the
three
the location of the
properties adjacent to this site those
four which encircle it on kolkata meadow
or whatever
are obviously spacious plots large
houses on spacious plots
for
not cramped but certainly into this site
um will again
uh
increase the density to my my mind
unnecessarily and i'm not sure i'm
inclined i think to agree with
councillor crump and his comments that
one is too many
so i'm thinking i'm not supportive of
the view that uh we should be agreeing
to this proposal thank you
thank you council dixon council jennings
i'm probably of the opposite opinion
but i think when you have when you have
uh
you're driving past it the mass when
you're looking at three houses in a row
it doesn't really whether
there are two or three i don't think
you'll notice it that much
um
there are larger gaps between the
between the properties now because it's
gone from three garages down to two
garages
the height has been reduced
um
okay it's only a small amount but if you
look at the smallest property they're
7.8 compared to 8.9
um
i'm struggling
i'd be struggling to
see this as over development but that's
just my view i wait to hear what
everyone else has to say
thank you cancer james cancer curtis
thank you chair um
just picking up on the point that's just
been made the um
the difference between the height ridge
height of the tallest of the highest of
the new of the new proposal is 8.7
against 8.9 so that's a it's a very
marginal difference but i think my
my key concern would be that i feel that
we
in this committee we really should give
sufficient weight to the views
of
of the town council the relevant town
council and the ward members
who
are not
against development but it is they are
in favor of the extant development which
has been approved i think as council
crump pointed out
and
it's obvious i know but this is an
increase of 33 percent
um it's not it's not a decrease it is an
increase over the extent um permission
that's been given
um and
it does say here you know the uh the
officer's report says
the full-back position is realistic
there's no evidence that it would not be
viable for this previous exam planning
permission to be carried out so i think
um
giving sufficient weight or giving
weight to the views of the ward member
and the town council the viable extant
permission again i would um
oppose this permission
thank you council curtis any other
members wish to speak before i put my
council reading
thank you chair um i think i'm minded
just to make it to all along with uh
councillor jennings
i think it's quite
spaced out and the removal of the
garages has given it
that ability to be and i think it'd be
quite hard to be um
defended against it
it being over development particularly
maybe with the inspector um as i'm
looking at it
i'll throw i'll throw it in there and
propose that we go along with the
officer's recommendation to grant them
i'll propose that that's right thank you
very much anyone else want to say
anything before i say what i think
councilman mills
oh here we go here we go yeah um i think
the um
developer's got it's gone some way to um
appease people i mean it is
lower the the height even it's marginal
but they're lower
um
to my mind it tends to be squeezing in
um
i think the development is quite good to
me
mr chairman so um
i will go along with the officer's
recommendation on this one thank you
is that a seconding of council eddon's
proposal
yeah
match no okay
thank you very much i'm very brief that
saves me doing it because i was going to
second that as well um
uh i'll just uh i i think i agree with
what council jones has said what council
edinburgh said
looking at this there's a lot more
spacing between the properties um
and therefore i've really i'm struggling
with it but you look at the previous
application it looks quite blocky
everything sort of is quite tight
together this gives it a little bit more
openness which is similar to i think
council dixon was talking about
properties nearby similar to they're not
the same size the properties but they're
still similar spacing for their sizes um
we've talked about viability of the
previous scheme
it's not a planning concern um we're
here to look at this application and its
merits and how it fits with policy
and for me i can find no policy reason
to go against it so on that basis i i
will be voting in
in line with four of my colleagues
certainly and hopefully a few more of
you
unless anyone says anything they want to
say at this point we'll move into a vote
move into a vote marvelous okay so the
proposal is to grant in line with the
officer's recommendation could i please
have a show of hands for those in favor
of that
one two three four five six seven are
those against
two therefore committee results to grant
application twenty one zero three eight
seven six ful tourist hotel in southam
marvelous
sorry
sorry
i need i need some new glasses
council can't you want to come do you
want to come and join us please
councillor crump
and we will move on to our next item
okay so our next item is uh application
210307 ful ormond lodge in new
bollinstown um our presenting officer is
once again aaron weatherson so erin over
to
you thank you chairman
the application site lies to the north
of new bold onstar settlement as
identified by the black dot on this plan
just here the village is identified as a
category three local service village
within the council's adopted core
strategy the site falls part within and
part outside of the draft bill to pair
your for the settlement as identified by
the emerging neighborhood development
plan and council site allocation plan
site comprises of a parcel of land
located to the east of the a4 300 set in
part within the felden parkland special
landscape area
the site lies adjacent to open parkland
you can see just here
and to the south of edington park which
is a grade one listed hotel which is
just here to the north
there's also an associated greater
garden temple and the remains of saint
nicholas's church located to the north
in this area
to the north of the site also lies grey
two littered south lodge which is
approximately here and across the road a
greater listed milestone structure
this slide shows the application site
outlined in red the pasta of land
includes open land which you can see
here almond lodge which is a dwelling
and its associated garden and existing
access onto the road
the site is on a higher level on the
road and the site slopes up to the east
planning permission is sort of the
erection of a new building containing
five residential dwellings and
associated works
this slide shows a proposed site plan
for the development the existing access
is proposed to be enlarged which you can
see just here and will also serve almond
lodge here with the enlarged parking in
access
the event will involve the demolition of
a number of smalling buildings within
the site to facilitate the development
and the new building will be located
close to the centre of the site just
here with parking located in this area
here and garden areas adjacent to almond
lodge garden just here to the west
the site has neighboring dwellings
located to the west and to the south you
can see just here on this plan
this slide shows the proposed floor
plans for the new building accommodation
is set across two levels with internal
staircases providing access you see
access just here to the upper levels
plot one is the largest dwelling which
is located just here which is three
bedroom with accommodation set across
two levels
the development also includes two two
bedroom dwellings on the ground floor
could you see here up here and here
and two one bedroom apartments
on the first floor one of the one
bedroom apartments has a study which is
large enough to be used as a single
bedroom and has been considered on this
basis
this slide shows proposed elevations for
the development the building includes
two gable features on each
elevation you can see here and here with
a central section
the building will be finished in
brickstone and render under a slate roof
be two stories in height measuring
approximately approximately nine meters
to the ridge and six meters to the eaves
the main architectural features will
face east towards the countryside and
it's this elevation here on the slide
you can see the bottom left
this slide shows a section and street
scene plan of the developments the top
plan shows a section you've got the road
just here
with almond lodge the new building
that's proposed with its parking and the
neighboring properties you can see just
here in the background which is south of
the development
the change in ground levels
approximately two meters from the road
up to the application site
the bottom plan on this slide is the
street scene looking from the road you
can see almond lodge just here and the
neighboring property just to the right
in grey and the new building can see
just here
in the center of the plan with the
access located just the left here
this slide shows a number of photographs
taken from the road to the west of the
site the top left is taken looking south
you can see allman lodge just here
and buildings beyond
the top right was taken of the access
you can see just here with the change in
ground levels with almond lodge located
just to the right
of the site just here the photograph
the bottom left is taken looking out to
the north with ormond lodge located to
the right and the application site is
just here
and the final photograph on this slide
was taken of almond lodge and the
neighbouring property you can see just
here from the road
this slide shows a number of photographs
taken from the street scene top left is
looking from the application sites the
ormond lodge here in a southerly
direction
top right was taken of the properties
located to the west of the road you see
the neighboring property is just here
opposite the application site
the next photograph down was taken
looking through the center of the
village and the final photograph was
taken with the application site on the
right
looking out of the settlement
this slide shows a number of photographs
taken from within the application site
the first the top left is looking in a
southerly direction towards the
neighbouring properties you can see just
here and then top right is panning
around you see almond lodge just here
and the neighboring property just here
with the road behind
looking down we've got a photograph
looking across the application site
to see just here and the final
photograph is looking towards the
countryside and existing vegetation is
visible in this photograph
there is an update for this application
which has been circulated on the update
sheet it's recommended that planning
permission be refused for the reason set
out in the officer report thank you
aaron thank you very much we will call
our first speaker on this item who has
counselor trevor harvey who is speaking
on behalf of tradington parish council
council harvey good evening welcome
thank you your patience
you know the drill you'll have three
minutes i'll give you a 30 second
warning before your time is up whenever
you're ready it is over to you
thank you mr chairman
the creation of five dwellings in
newborn contributes to the housing needs
assessment requirements this development
will provide small properties for rent
and contribute to the need for
affordable housing
the latest housing survey was completed
in january twenty twenty to suggest that
because it is little more than two years
old weakens its findings is surprising
especially in a rural settlement where
change takes place gradually indeed the
2020 findings are very similar to those
of a similar survey in 2013.
the parish council acknowledges that
part of the site
site plan sits outside the buav proposed
in both the neighborhood plan and the
sap
however it's within the cartilage of
ormond lodge
the buab is not in place and should not
therefore be used to challenge this
application
the parish council disagrees that the
development does not conform to the
provisions of as10 or
cs15 or para 80 of the nppf
furthermore whilst the development may
be seen from the special landscape area
judicious landscaping around the new
building would mitigate the impact on
the surrounding countryside
new world is a line development along
the a 3400 this building would conform
to the pattern of development that has
taken place since the 1950s and it is
not inappropriate
the parish council sees this as infill
rather than an extension of the village
boundary
while the building might change the
landscape to describe it as causing
visual harm is a little alarmist when
set against all the development that has
taken place in the village over the past
five years it is also a highly
subjective statement
the addition of these properties will
bring the total number of houses built
in newbold since july 2016
209 at least one recent
application appeal was supported by the
inspector who asserted that while
certain allocations were made under cs16
there was no cap on the number of houses
to be built in settlements
the property density of 24 houses per
hectare is roughly in line with the
neighborhood plan policy which seeks a
reduced housing density
two parking spaces for each property and
a bike shed are provided all meeting
neighborhood plan policy requirements
the site is elevated about four feet
above the road it'll be shielded in part
however by almond lodge which is being
refurbished furthermore the removal of
the adjacent site as a reserve housing
site as proposed in the latest asap
will screen the development from the
north thank you mr chairman
perfect thank you very much uh council
harvey uh do you have any questions
council jennings first
i appreciate you may not be able to
answer this
because you're not on the
parish council but uh
it's uh
they did raise some concerns regarding
highway matters
are you able to elaborate on that
yeah i am
yes they do have concerns uh i'm not
sure
frankly i'm not sure it's a planning
matter for this committee but they uh
anybody who knows as can i know cancer
curtis does knows very well the approach
to
um
newbold from the north is a long
straight road
and the police have um caught people
uh doing more than 100 miles an hour and
prosecuted
and what the parish council would be in
favor of is
uh currently it goes from a 60 limit
yes it is a 60 limit down to 30. what
they would like is a buffer zone of 40
limit
and they would like uh they they would
have preferred that i had made that
included that within the statement uh in
order that it might be a condition on on
the on the grant if it was if it was to
be granted on the basis the developer
would meet some of the costs as opposed
to the costs fully falling on the on as
we would know the county council um but
it it speeding as everybody knows who
who represents a rural village speeding
through rural villages is a persistent
problem
thank you very much harvey any other
questions council crump
thank you mr councilman harvey
one of the reasons for refusal is the
failure to integrate with the
density and settlement plan at the
sensitive edge of the settlement
location and erode the rural character
i just like your thoughts on that do you
agree that it would erode the rural
character of the settlement
uh frankly no for two reasons one is i
think that the screening that's already
evident as you can see in that
photograph and you may see in others
later um would mask this site quite a
lot and secondly the fact which hasn't
been mentioned
is that uh the the the new building will
lie i measured it as as 65 and a bit
feet it's about 20 meters from from the
pathway from from the the from the
pavement so the building lies
a considerable way back from the road um
and i think councillor harvey i think
you've answered the question i i'm gonna
have to stop you there sorry um uh
councillor curtis please
thank you and yes cancer harvey
you mentioned that the um
the new building may be seen from former
parkland and it says in the report
prominence of the site is exacerbated by
the open former parkland to the north
and east but i just want to
are you are there any public footpaths
that you're aware of across that
parkland where
the new building would be visible from
sorry can't answer that no no i'm not
sure that's concise we'll perhaps we'll
bring that back to our offices later on
then we'll be able to answer that and
similarly with i think with the uh 30 40
and 60 mile an hour zones we'll have to
ask i don't think it's our gift to do
that but we'll find out um i have a
question for you if i may um is almond
house it's you so you talked about the
cartilage of this being in the kurdish
woman house being outside the buab is
almond house itself
within the buab
there is no buab at the moment
there is only a proposed buab there's
lodge lies in as far as the neighborhood
plan is concerned
almond lodge lies inside itself lies
inside the buab
but the sub but the boav is part of that
splits the site
okay that's helpful that is helpful
thank you very much
anyone else with any questions before we
go i mean council harvard is coming back
later on as wall members so
if you think of more i'm sure we can
pepper him then i was going to ask
something about the bu a m b but um i'm
confused now well i'm confused mr
chairman now it just says the um
developments outside the built-up area
boundary i just wonder if that was
contrary to the ndp
your ndp
the cash council's ndp or published
council's independence council's ndp has
currently drafted as currently drafted
which means it could change has orman
lodge and its media vicinity
inside the buab
the proposed development on that basis
lies outside the buab
but there is one cartilage for almond
lodge which is the whole plot which
includes bits a portion inside and a
portion outside the proposed buab
that exactly answers the question i
asked before as well so which is which
is the information i wanted um okay so
unless there's any other questions
uh in that case counseling thank you
very much
okay we will move to our next speaker on
this item who is christian lawrence
architect mrs lawrence thank you for
your patience do you come forward
so in a similar way you will have three
minutes i'll give you a 30 second
warning and whenever you're ready if you
press the button in the middle it will
go red and the floor is yours
thank you chairman and committee members
for giving me the opportunity to talk in
support of the full planning application
the application before you today would
provide the five number much needed
private market rental dwellings within
the village of newborn stour the
application has support from the parish
council and no objections from all
statutory consultees
this identifies the development is
located within ghana land torment lodge
not characteristic of agricultural land
as outlined by the planning officer
there is a strong visible difference on
site which is defined by dense hedgerow
and fence line to the eastern boundary
of the site
the council's own policy officer is
consistent with the information set out
within the planning representation that
the line of the boundary is not the
determinative factor over whether or not
the site this site falls within the
physical confines of the village but
rather it requires an assessment of the
on-ground conditions and planning
judgment to be made
based on the facts on the ground in this
case it is clear that the application
site isn't
not only comprises the existing
residents occurred to the divorman lodge
there's existing built development
positions beyond three of the
applications site boundaries comprising
established residential and commercial
uses the development located beyond the
three site boundaries gives the
application site an info character as a
matter of planning judgment it is
concluded that the site is positioned
within the physical confines of the
village
in terms of the proposed scale height
and sighting of the building the
proposed building character
characteristically responds to the
existing ormond lodge enhancing the
strong architectural design and
appearance the building is a of a linear
two-story form and is consistent with
the surrounding properties with
properties further northwest of the
sites away from the village boundary
being two-story and longer larger
properties
the proposal effectively balances the
three roles of the sustainable
development and meets with the overall
planning objectives of the mppf and
stratfor upon having core strategy
the presumption in favor of development
applies and a new development would make
a significant contribution to
small-scale private rental market for
newborns tower
there are no significant or adverse
impacts arising from the development to
outweigh the benefits thank you for your
time and i hope you can look to support
the proposals and overturn your office's
recommendation for a refusal
mr lawrence that's well within your time
thank you very much remember to have any
questions for our architects please
council crumb i've got two if you don't
mind mr chairman
first of all
mr lawrence did get his surname right
this good stuff um
just confirmed a bit of
about the physical confines of the
village
and then i'll come back on the second
one
in what respect sorry with regards to
the site itself yeah
you were saying about
other properties and industrial units
further so so to the north there's some
grey buildings to the north of the site
they have a been used for commercial use
they were a coach builder for a number
of years um up until recently when the
uh the tenant of hormone lodge had
passed away um and they were they're
part of the
site ownership will be outside of the
red line boundary
thank you for that
and the second one um expect the
properties um
the parish council alluded to they would
be small properties to rent and
affordable
properties
are there any other
similar ones and thereby um you know
are yours quite unique i'll you know and
the need for them really basically
so the uh my clients uh desire for these
was for them to be a market rental
property um
i suppose the difference being that
they're
single story for a single story living
in terms of one bed apartments there's a
three-story house and first four
apartments which i don't believe is very
characteristic of the village and that's
something he wanted to provide for the
village as such albeit market rental
thank you council dixon
my question was answered with the first
response because the officer indicated
that the
boundaries and i did wonder what those
properties were on the north but
okay
anyone else have any questions they
would like to ask
no in that case mr thanks very much for
your time contribution thank you
okay we'll move to our final speak on
this item who is councillor trevor
harley council harvey please do come
forward
and this time you've got five minutes
with a 30 second warning you can use as
much or as little as that five minutes
as you like
whenever you're ready thank you before i
start
the clock start ticking can i be assured
that the slides will come up in
accordance with the statement as i read
it
helpful and then i'll do it like that's
okay
thank you mr chairman
slide one
almond lodge was occupied until his
death last year by rod mr rod osb mr
oosby was the tenant of ormond lodge
from which he ran a business uh oz osbee
carriages building and restoring coaches
and providing horse-drawn carriages for
weddings and funerals the business
related workshops are within the
boundaries of the ground it is
understood mr ooze be rented from his
landlord in other words the area
occupied and rented that forms almond
lodge was the entire plot whether it
currently lies inside or outside the
proposed buab
the new world buab is merely at proposal
stage as one element of the site
allocations plan
as the case officer points out in the
absence of an approved buab annex 4 of
the site allocations plan provides a
methodology for identifying land that is
to be included within a buab
one of the elements is that excuse me is
that land quote
on employment and commercial sites on
the edge of a settlement quote should be
included in the buab on this basis
therefore the entire plot that forms
almond lodge should be regarded as lying
within the buab or put another way it's
a nonsense for a boa boundary to dissect
a single plot
slide two
the case officer does not consider the
site falls within the physical confines
of newbold
in the absence of an approved buab and
on the basis of the use of part of the
site for employment and commercial
purposes the entire plot of almond lodge
would meet the test for inclusion in a
boab
its close proximity to its immediate
neighboring property to the south is in
stark contrast for example to the
separation of the two houses across the
road park edge and tolbert edge that are
separated from their immediate neighbor
to the south by a field of allotments a
distance of some 70 yards
yet both these properties are included
within the proposed buab
as a small scale development that lies
within the physical confines of a
limited service village it is argued
therefore that this proposal does indeed
meet the principles of as10
the case officer's argument in relation
to cx cs16 and the number of dwellings
to be provided is a case of heads i win
tails you lose
when this argument has been put to the
planning inspectors in the past i.e
we've already exceeded the 59 houses
we're meant to be building the
reply has always been that this is an
indicative minimum
not a set maximum
development has never been refused in
newbold on this basis now the argument
is stood on its head and it's argued
that an arbitrary number of 105
dwellings is the maximum and no more can
be permitted
yet the terms of cx 16 have not changed
slide three
case officer objects to the scale and
the prominence of this development it's
asserted that it would detract from the
edge of settlement of the settlement
setting and yet
permission has been implemented for a
multi-development
multi-dwelling development in the center
of newbold and it too is immediately
adjacent to the a-3400
the recently built saint david's terrace
lies immediately north of saint david's
church
it comprises six dwellings a combination
of studio one bedroom and two bedroom
units on a footprint of
268 square meters
an area larger than the footprint of the
ormond lodge proposal of
square meters
where's the consistency in approving one
and refusing the other on the grounds of
scale
slide four
the case officer objects to the proposed
building on the grounds that citing it
to the rear of ormond lodge would be
contrary to the pattern of development
within within the locality of the site
and yet this is this proposal is not
unique
in the next door village of treadington
such an arrangement has already been
approved on a site that is equally
immediately adjacent to the a 3400 this
is the instance of oak lawn house where
permission was granted for it to be
built to the rear of dawn cottage 30
seconds i argue therefore that this
development does meet the requirements
of as10 that the terms of cs16 have been
applied in a way which is inconsistent
with past decisions of planning
inspectors and that the case officers
subjective judgments concerning the
sighting and visual impact of the
proposed building
are open to challenge
thank you mr chairman
casa harvey thank you very much indeed
members do we have any questions for
councillor harvey council dixon please
in the report on page 46 erin writes
when considering all of the
site-specific factors i do not consider
that the site when viewed as a whole
would fall within the physical confines
of the settlement the application has
been assessed on this basis do you are
you of the opinion that if she had not
come to that conclusion the assessment
may indeed have been for grant rather
than to refuse
i don't know that's a question you
should ask her
thank you i think i would agree with
your counselor harvey
um are there any other relevant
questions that we can ask councillor
harvey please
members no okay and that says council
harvey thank you very much time
contribution this evening
let's move to our point of clarification
for our offices we do have some that we
have heard of throughout
um the
written on a different page forgive me
um the speeding suggestion that we heard
earlier from 60 to 40 to 30 is it within
our gift to in
to do that or will we need to have um
the i suspect we need to have the
highways the county council consulted on
it i mean in terms of this application
highways have raised no objections
subject to conditions and notes to the
current proposal as submitted
so even if we did put it on that would
be subject to um challenge i presume and
we don't really have much strength
in that situation yeah so to confirm
county highways haven't requested a
conditional legal agreement to change um
the speed limits in the area so putting
it on would be um we'd be risking
challenge against that conditional 106.
okay marvellous thank you very much
council jennings next please
housing needs surveys i mean i know
we've been pushing these a lot um but
the there was a comment that
because it was done in 2020 that it's
um
you're affording it less weight
i'm just thinking that with covert at
the moment that's probably the most
up-to-date
possible to do it housing needs survey
and have there been any more recent ones
and when does it become out of date so
it's matter of judgment i think in this
case we just have to have regard to the
age of the document and but what we're
considering here isn't a local needs
scheme so it's helpful for reference to
consider it as part of the principle of
the development but what we're looking
at here is open market dwellings and
we've not got a local knee scheme that's
come forward so that's how we're
considering as officers so it's just
helpful the parish has suggested it
would meet the smaller units they would
like to see in the in the parish but in
terms of the housing need it's not
considered to meet any of the need
identified by the housing needs survey
and it's been put forward for open
market dwellings on this occasion
council mills
thanks mr chairman um erin
this question of the built-up area
boundary does it run through
the middle of this plot so there's no
adopted built-in period boundary for the
settlement right we've got the draft
that's coming through if i just go
through on the slide it's coming right
yeah i should be able to find that for
you so in this case we have to have
regard to it but limited weight can be
afforded to the draft-built period
boundaries so it's a physical confines
assessment that we've carried out as
part of this assessment in line with the
methodology in annex four i understand
so that's what we have to have regard to
that it's a case-by-case basis and a
matter of planning judgment if it's in
or out of the physical confines could i
ask another question um
what if we could put the slide up of
exactly where
this is proposed development please in
the back garden of
whatever cottage it was so this is the
application site outlined in red and
you've got the dwelling here which is
almond lodge in the garden area and the
access going down and the new
development will be just here so just to
show it on the site plan the gardens
here access is here and then this is the
application site which is beyond the
garden um i understand of warm and lodge
so we're looking at in terms of the
draft build a pair of boundaries i'll
just bring those up just because it's
helpful and so you can see where the
change is in terms of
[Music]
so you can see just here the application
site you've got almond lodge here so
it's part in part out of the built up
area boundary as draft and this is from
the site allocations plan i just
bring
yep
okay are you happy
you got one more
go ahead so mr chairman and
can you put up the photograph please of
where this site is going
it's in the background module
so i'll just go back so it's the plan
you wanted to see
so it might be
well i'm not clear what you want to see
either to be honest with you can
something else is it a plan of or a
specific photo
now you've got the garden here for
almond lodge and it's this land here
that's fine exactly okay sorry
okay anyone else with points okay sorry
council curtis thank you just just
picking up the um point that was made at
the end of council harvey's present
second
appearance um
page 46 aaron will you say when
considering all the specific facts
factors
i do not consider the site when viewed
as a whole
would fall within the physical confines
if you
if it were to be considered that it fell
within the physical confines of the
settlement
would that have changed your view
so in terms of the planning assessment
the two core strategy policies are as10
and cs15 and they do support development
on sites um through small-scale schemes
on unidentified but it's a suitable site
in the built pair of boundaries where
defined or physical confines of a local
service village so it's that assessment
if it's within the physical confines we
would assess the principle of the
development differently
can i just just to really confirm the
um draft
what would be the buab which is in draft
or whatever at the moment
does cut right across the middle
of the site yes so it's partying in part
outside so the almond lodge in the
garden area this sort of area here is
within and it's the new building is
outside of the draft but the new
building it is all within the cartilage
of ormond lodge so we've assessed it and
having regard to the methodology and the
application sites for all of the land
so whilst it might have been used
associated with almond lodge we've
assessed this as a whole and that's why
cumulatively we consider it outside of
the physical confines
fine okay thank you
do we have do we have any more questions
or points of clarification for our
officers or shall we move to the debate
let's move into the debate who wants to
kick us off councillor dixon
thank you chairman
i disagree with everyone's assessment
that it's outside of the
built-up area
not boundary but outside the physical
confines of the settlement
we've heard that the draft coab will
include or all possibly already does
include the two properties to the along
the other side of the road etc uh and
that this site was excluded from the
draft proposals and what have you but to
my mind it is on
it is within the confines or very close
to the confines and therefore i disagree
with that statement that is considered
to be outside and therefore i think the
application should be approved on the
basis that it would then fall within the
uh delta variability etc is that a
proposal yes
okay can i just check your mic is on
yes it did yeah it was i think it was
quite long away from you so we're trying
to tell you but i think you'd have been
picked up so that's a proposal to grant
um
i'm going to second that um while i've
got the microphone and i'll come to you
in a second and cancel this if i may um
i'm going to try and expand on that a
little bit and give reasons why we're
going against the officer's
recommendation
um so
uh i agree with you the builder boundary
is in draft form um it can still change
his subject is still subject to change
on the basis that uh the cartilage is
part in part out it makes sense that the
cartilage would be included within um
there's built form directly above that
when looking at the uh buab as proposed
as drafters those are outside
so i would suggest that they should
probably be included
so i disagree with that assessment and i
think we can um uh we can move against
that
it's so rare
if ever it happens
that we have a parish council and a ward
member who come and say yes we've taken
our quota but quite happy to say more i
don't think i've ever heard that um and
i i think to a point that council curtis
made earlier on um we we do have to
consider the uh opinions and
information put forward evidence put
forward by uh parish councils and
ward members
we can take a different view but in this
instance i don't
and i think one of the key things that
has swayed this for me particularly as
well and i think um i want i definitely
want this noted uh is that
the um the housing lead assessment that
was done in 2020 i still think that's
relevant it's not that long ago of
course it changes a housing needs
assessment that was done yesterday could
be very different from one that's done
tomorrow because things change very
quickly it is a snapshot in time but i
still think it's very relevant
because it meets that and as we've heard
from the both parish council and the war
member
it very much does meet that i think that
is um
out clearly outweighs any harm that has
been or could be identified so on that
basis i am seconding and i'm going to
assume you're happy with everything i've
said as reasons to go against the
officer's recommendation perfect council
curtis did you want to say something at
this point
that i was prepared to second the the
i'm assuming you're happy as well but
we'll uh unless anyone else wants to
speak cancer crumb
it's a shame you didn't listen to the
ward member and the team council the
previous one but we won't go there
but uh
seriously uh this is apologies for um i
agree um
it is rare that uh the ward member in
the parish council agree there is this
need especially when the numbers met
we've heard that its fault it doesn't
erode the royal character
because of the screening it's a way back
from the road there's been an agreement
it's within the physical confines of the
village and mixed principles is-10
and again
they mentioned the infill
improves the character of the land
densities um so yeah um and again the
bib been dissecting the single plot is
is probably a bit uh
unique as you called it i could think of
other words but
we'll settle for unique so um yeah i'm
fully in supportive of your
whoever's proposed it and supported it
so yeah thank you
thank you council crump um another thing
i'd like to add as well if i may uh to
our reasons policy cs16 as we've heard
and we've been told many times here it's
not a cap it's not an absolute maximum
it is a recommended number um
and clearly obviously we're exceeding
that but it is just a recommendation
it's not a maximum um okay we need to
think about conditions don't we um do
you have a list of conditions prepared
yeah of course alice please do
erin does have conditions so we can
revert to her in a moment a couple of
things i just want to clarify um one of
the points you um made councillor
richardson is in respect of the housing
needs survey i completely take the point
that members want to give it full weight
rather than less weight as as we've kind
of said the only thing i just wanted to
clarify is that what's proposed here
doesn't strictly comply with the needs
that are sat with the housing needs
survey and i think he says that it it
does meet it so i just wanted to clarify
that i think the point that um the board
member and the parish were making is
that it
it wants smaller units and this is
smaller units albeit not in exact form
so i just wanted to clarify that
and the other thing is that obviously
that uh we've got um an assessment on
the reason for refusal one i understand
i haven't heard any reasons for uh
granting in relation to the reason for
refusal two in terms of character so you
can just clarify and confirm um that you
are satisfied that the impact on
character is acceptable that would be
appreciated uh both points taken and
understood on the first point yes um
that's as in line with the parish
council and the uh war member on the
second point um uh i'm satisfied that it
does
so conditions please
thank you so a number of um proposed
conditions just that the headings i've
got at the moment so it'd be three years
approved plans materials sample panel
for the stone hard and soft landscaping
and tree protection levels just because
of the change from the road to the site
and how significant that is drainage and
then we've got highways conditions as
recommended fire and rescue condition
environmental health contamination and
remediation archaeological condition
ecology condition and then our standard
bins water books climate change
checklist broadband an electric vehicle
charging point also notes just put in
the mppf the highways note the fire and
rescue note and a note just to make
reference that all the landscaping will
be considered as part of the condition
i'm entirely happy with that members are
there any other conditions cancer dixon
has proposed are you happy
i'm very happy yes any other conditions
you may want to put on
no
okay brilliant in that case let's move
to the vote so the proposal is to grant
for the reasons given could i please and
for the conditions that we've just heard
could i please have a show of hands for
those in favor
of unanimous so committee therefore
resolves to grant application
2103077 ful ormond lodge for the reasons
given and with those conditions
um members um we've been going for an
hour and 20 minutes i'm gonna take two
minutes for a quick comfort break it
will be a strict two minutes please so
as soon as we're back we will start
going again thank you very much
okay uh ladies and gentlemen members we
are back now um thank you very much for
that brief uh interlude okay so our next
item is 2200 362 ful two river mead
barton road in welford on avon our
presenting officer sarah chadwick sarah
over to you
thank you chairman the application
before members tonight is a section 73
application which seeks to vary
condition two which relates to the plans
and condition three materials a planning
permission reference 1901 960 fur which
was for the erection of a single story
rear extension and detached garage the
section 73 application seeks to
regularize various changes to the
approved scheme including revised
external facing materials and the eaves
height
the application is retrospective in
nature
the application site is within an open
countryside location between
uh welfare naval and barton and can be
seen outlined by the red line on this
plan there's a public right-of-way
indicated by the dashed green line to
the north of the site and the pink line
indicates the river avon
this slide shows the elevations as
approved under the full application at
the top with the
uh
front elevation of the attached garage
shown on the left and the detached
garage shown on the right
with the proposed elevation subject this
subject of the section 73 application
shown at the bottom of the slide the
principal changes to the scheme include
revised external facing materials to the
garage and rear extension revised eve
eaves heights to the rear extension the
full extent of the changes are listed in
the officer report
here we see a photo of the front
elevation the dwelling and the extended
attached garage on the left and the
detached garage on the right as built
out
chairman the design alterations the
original scheme are considered to be
acceptable as is the impact of the
alterations on neighbouring amenity the
recommendation is therefore to grant
subject to the conditions as detailed on
page 64 of the agenda thank you
so thank you very much um our first
speaker on this item is council
councillor neil appleton
councillor good evening and welcome
thank you for your patience
whenever you're sat comfortable and
ready if you press the button in the
middle the uh it should go red and
you'll have three minutes i'll give you
a 30 second warning but the floor is now
yours
okay good evening councillors um yeah
the pc considered this application on
the first of march and again on the 22nd
of march to consider additional material
was submitted by the applicant
um
as was stated it's a retrospective
application
presumed as a result of enforcement
action or something similar
um the pc objected on two points um
both from our enabled design
design plan which is the
design excellence hlu2 and the impact on
neighbour which is hlu5
i note that only
our objection from the 26th of march
22nd of march is included within the
officers case report
our primary objection is on
design excellence
and the pc largely agree with the points
made by the case officer on uh impact on
visual event
impact on public visual immunity and
insofar as the
impact is minimal however
visual immunity and design excellence
are not one and the same thing and so we
feel our objection stands
in the context of the current
application understanding the design
aesthetic of the whole development
informs what we mean and understand by
design excellence
so for this particular development um
the inspiration for all five residences
at rivermead
is that of a traditional war extra
timber barn
the design features for a traditional
workshop timber barn are timber frame
timber cladding hinged timber doors and
like any other barn in this locality a
shallow pitch roof
in this particular application they have
used composite cladding
a grey aluminium roller door
and they use a steeper
roof pitch
so there's very little of the barn
aesthetic which remains
we have an additional point of variation
that has not been considered by the case
officer and it's the ridge height of the
old garage which you can see
to the left of the property now the pc
understand that there has been no change
in the structure of this
element of the build and therefore the
ridge height is the same as it was
previously
however we are not approving the
building we are approving the plan
and the new plan appears to have a
different ridge height than the original
plan
so
on that basis
the new ridge height would impact we
believe on the balkan mass but more
importantly on the street scene
because these dwellings in river mead
all have the same design
30 seconds thank you hence the pc you
maintain that the application fails to
deliver on design excellence and it may
well deliver on visual immunity but on
design excellence it fails
the final point is on labour amenity uh
naval impact um the pc objected
originally in 2019 the garage was
overbearing on the neighbor due to its
close proximity to the boundary
um the applicant moved it they agreed
with us that
with our objection however the
garage is actually located 0.5 of a
meter closer to the boundary again and
so we've projected again on this same
point i'm afraid that is your time up so
i'm going to switch it
unless you're done oh perfect sorry
any questions are welcome
members do any questions cancel
yannick's first please
okay
does that cutting look like wood to you
it does look like wood but it doesn't
you can see the wood as of the neighbors
garage there
next to it and that's silver gray that's
where the timber
and the
plastic composite
um is supposed to look like timber
but that is
not the barn aesthetic that you would
see if you
if you if you wander around that
location um you will find many examples
of
barns and none of them are actually
brown they're grey because all the
timber has weathered
thank you very much members do we have
any other questions
for the parish council please
no
in that case mr appleton council after i
should say thank you very much for your
time contribution this evening and your
patience
okay we'll call our next speaker who is
dominick skinner and i believe is with
uh matt williamson is that correct um
you're here to answer questions is that
right so you're perfectly welcome to
stay seated where you are until we need
you if that's all right um otherwise
we'll hear from mr skinner so mr skinner
you'll have three minutes 30 second
warning
i can see you're already on so whenever
you're ready the floor is yours
thank you chair
this application seeks a variation of
condition of a previous approval due to
alterations required during construction
the application has been supported by
the planning officer uh the parish
council has objected to location of the
garage the use of composite timber
cladding
eaves and ridge height of the garage and
extension and alteration to the garage
doors
the position of the garage is
approximately half a meter closer to the
neighboring boundary yet is still 60
meters from the nearest point of the
neighboring dwelling
the planning office
officer has stated that the current
sighting is suitably distant not to
cause harm to the residential immunity
of the neighboring dwelling with no
harmful impact due to overshadowing or
overbearing
the original planning application stated
the facing material of the development
would be timber cladding with no other
stipulation on the type of material
required
the proposed use of composite timber
cladding seeks best to match the
original cladding in color texture and
horizontal insulation and is in keeping
with the original dwelling
the proposed cladding offers a low
maintenance and sustainable solution the
planning officer has concluded that this
does not cause visual harm to the
character of the area
there has been no increase in ridge
height of the proposed development in
relation to the approved plants
the eaves height of both the garage and
extension have been reduced by half a
meter to better match the existing
dwelling this reduction also visually
reduces the amount of the development
and is more in keeping with the existing
house
solar panels have been included on the
extension with a proposed developed
window moved to the opposite side of the
roof
no windows face the neighboring dwelling
the doors to the new detached garage
were previously drawn to appear
barn-like and have been changed to
roller shutter doors for improved
security and ease of use a feature which
matches several properties on this road
the planning officer states that these
minor alterations harmonize with the
local dwelling and are in accordance
with policy cs20
a number of rejections have been
arranged by
have been raised by a joining neighbor
these have been considered by the
planning officer as part of her
assessment
with none offering material
consideration from all grounds to
refusal
we agree with the planning office's
assessment that these alterations do not
cause harmful impact to the character of
the area neighboring amenity and
harmonize with existing dwelling
therefore we respectfully ask the
committee to approve the application
thank you members chair mr skinner thank
you very much indeed members do we have
any questions councillor jennings please
instead of using real timber was
composite used just to save money or is
there any other technical reason
the
the composite cladding was used to for a
number of reasons to maintain the the
colour of the existing dwelling so when
the dwellings were actually built
the colour of the cladding was almost
exactly as you see there on on the
proposal now if you actually look
have you ever had the opportunity to
look further down the street buildings
don't all weather
uniformly
so there are some examples of cladding
still looking very similar to to what is
proposed
and
the
the composite cladding in its nature is
a sustainable material so it's made of
recycled timber and recycled plastic it
also offers a a low maintenance
opportunity for the client to which we
feel is more sustainable than a timber
cladding option
thank you members any other questions
for
mr skinner
no in that case just kind of thank you
very much for your time and contribution
and thanks for your patience as well
okay we have no further question uh no
further speakers i should say on on that
item so let's move to points
clarification for officers anyone got
anything they would like to ask
no
councillor mills thanks for sharing it
it was a big sort of big question mark
over this cladding could i could i see
the um i think it was
the photograph of this um with with the
um
you've got the solar panels on the top
of that
the one with the roller doors yeah
no it's a photographer
oh
that's it is it
right in there roller doors
okay
i've seen that that's a thing
castle jennings can you turn your
microphone on please i apologize is it
possible to zoom in on the picture
just to get a better idea of this
composite cladding because looking at
the picture on the right
obviously that's i'm presuming that
that's seizure or timber cladding next
next to composite
so this this is a the rear elevation of
the detached garage it might be a
slightly better view let me see if
there's another one
so that's composite yeah
i've got another one there
first one's probably better
okay any other questions members for our
points of clarification
no let's move into the debate who would
like to kick us off
i'll pick on someone if they don't
council jennings thank you
i don't like the composite cladding
i wouldn't i would it sort of ruins
ruins the look um i but i appreciate
designers subjective i don't have the
problem with any of the other
aspects of it
um
solar panels
yup houses need them these days but i
really don't like that cladding at all
i think they've ruined the house but
it's their own house
again design is subjective i guess
thank you very much um anyone else
council dixon
but our job i think is also to support
good design
and i agree with council jennings um
i do not like the
classic nature and the fact that
the other properties locally etc
yes
oak cladding will
uh
shade and change color over years and it
will not change uniformly but that's
part of the
the nature of of timber it's almost a
bit like comparing upvc windows with
timber windows
one is very much an artificial long-term
maintenance one and the other one is far
more
rural in nature
so i must admit i do not like the
planning either
cancer cases
really agreeing with those
previous two comments
we should be looking at as as was
mentioned design excellence
and the original
timber barn doors
do seem to be far more in keeping with
the rural nature
and
maybe design is subjective but
i wouldn't want that next to my house
okay thank you anyone else
hang on a second counseling serving are
you wanting to speak i can see your
finger poised over the button go ahead
yeah um
just a bit of clarification are the
windows plastic or wood
do we know
um i believe the windows are described
as cream aluminium windows
okay thank you
council jennings you want a second about
the cherry i was just going to say
what's the point of material conditions
if they're ignored on the first place
i'm going to agree with you on that and
i'm going to agree with everyone said it
does frustrate me when
we have conditions placed and
changes material changes are made i
think this both the roller doors and the
cladding cause significant harm to the
visual amenity of that street um
i'm not
design excellence as we've heard from
the parish council um we should be
looking for excellent design i'm not
sure if that is a policy that we can
uh
put through
but certainly i think this is uh this
has material visual um hull causes
material visual harm to the street scene
and and the area um
unless anyone's got anything to say
uh i'm we might we're gonna have to look
for a proposal in a second um i'm
inclined to do it if anyone else i don't
want to assume no one else is going to
do it just bear with me
page 61 if we decide that the planning
permission should be granted subject to
the same conditions as those subject to
which the previous permission was
granted then they should refuse the
application
but i'd like to propose that
i'm going to agree with that in that
case i'm going to second i think we need
to add a little bit more to it and i
think particularly the reason why we're
not prepared to grant this variation is
because
what is there materially impacts the
visual amenity of the street scene
and and the area um
i don't think much more is needed i'm
struggling to find much more but i think
that is pretty strong um and based on
the general feeling and the nothing i'm
seeing i think everyone's pretty much in
agreement
so
have you got what you need from us yes
if i can just clarify um so i've noted
down that members are minded to refuse
the application as the in particular
materials cause harm to the streets in
an area and therefore i'm assuming that
it would be contrary to policy cs9 and
members minds correct okay thank you
okay uh on that basis we have a proposal
uh has been seconded to refuse the
reasons given because i will show hands
for those in favor of refusal
one two three you know
you left me hanging for a minute cancer
adam
so members there for resolve to refuse
application twenty two zero zero three
six two very uh two river meet uh bottom
road in welford on haven
okay we will move to our final item of
the evening which is application 2200
992 ful and adjacent to valley road in
elswood our president's conferences once
again sarah chadwick sarah whenever
you're ready it's over to you
is
thank you chairman
this is a full planning application for
the installation of a cctv camera and
column the application site is located
outside of the draft boat of area
boundary of ellsworth in an open
countryside location and is denoted by
the black dot on this plan
the proposed camera location is
indicated indicated by the red dot on
this plan the site is within the west
midlands greenbelt and arden special
landscape area is also within flood zone
3 and a local wildlife site and s triple
s i are located nearby
here we see a mock-up image of the
proposed camera in situ the camel would
be at a height no higher than 12 meters
this image is taken excuse me this image
is taken facing in the northerly
direction the camera and supporting
column are proposed to be cited on the
area of hardstanding adjacent to the
fencing in the centre of the photo
chairman the development does not meet
any of exceptions to inappropriate
development set out in the mppf however
very special circumstances have been
identified and are considered to
outweigh the harm caused the green belt
the development is therefore acceptable
in principle and the recommendation is
to grant subject to the conditions as
detailed on page 72 of the agenda thank
you
so thank you very much we've got no
registered speakers and so we'll move to
points for clarification has anyone got
a point that they would want clarifying
um i'll just ask um you said it'd be no
higher than 12 meters do we know
exactly how high we're going to be
i'm afraid that's that's all the
information i have on the height okay
that's a shame okay not a problem uh
let's move to debate who would like to
kickstart counselor dixon
thank you chairman i've not been
involved in this uh application at all
since i'm able to speak as the ward
member um without having made any pre-de
pre-determination uh the whole of the
community the residents the parish
council are fully in support of this it
might be outside the built-up bay area
boundary but i don't think that's a
relevant aspect and i would propose that
we grant the
permission in accordance with the
officer's recommendation
thank you very much cancer crumb i'm
happy to second that proposal
marvellous unless anyone else has
anything to say we'll move to a vote
anyone else want to say anything no good
let's move to a vote everyone in favor
unanimous therefore committee resolves
to grant application 2200 992 furland
jason's valley road in earlsword
unless there is any urgent business
there's no urgent business in that case
it leaves me to say thank you very much
to all my members to all the officers
for all the time and contributions this
evening we will close there soon in a
couple of weeks thank you very much